philippe bas comment réagissez vous
quelle est votre réponse au refus
d'alexandre benalla de venir témoigner
devant la commission d'enquêté le 19
septembre prochain
j'espère que ce refus provisoire bien
sûr parce qu'il n'appartient à personne
convoqué devant une commission denquête
de décider si oui ou non il doit venir
je rappelle que c'est une convocation
celui qui vient pas s'exposer à des
peines de prison et d'amendés celui qui
ment il s'expose à des peines encore
plus graves et une commission denquête
c'est au nom du peuple français
la représentation nationale qui veut
faire la vérité et qui veut ensuite
faire des recommandations des
propositions pour le bon fonctionnement
de l'état est ce que vous croyez que
c'est normal que monsieur benalla
s'exprime à tf1 s'exprime dans le
journal du dimanche s'exprime dans le
monde et que seul endroit où il ne parle
pas c'est la représentation nationale
il a dit lui même j'ai envie eh bien
nous lui offrons l'occasion de
s'expliquer
naturellement sans jamais poser la
moindre question sur des faits qui font
l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire parce
que moi je suis très sourcilleux sur ce
principe là et vous le savez d'ailleurs
j'ai eu l'occasion souvent de le dire
la séparation des pouvoirs est une chose
sacrée je la défends et je suis même à
la commission des lois
assez vigilants sur cette question nous
lui posons bien sûr aucune question sur
les fêtes de l'enquète ça d'ailleurs
c'est une passe qui nous intéresse tout
ceci le 1er mai moi je m'intéresse plus
tôt à ce qui s'est passé avant et est ce
qui s'est passé après c'est à dire le
fonctionnement de l'état avait-il reçu
une convocation en bonne et due forme
on a pu voir l'avocat d'alexandre reynal
a présenté un mail sur lequel on pouvait
lire que la commission denquête
demandait à ce qu'il vienne le 19
septembre prochain et ce n'est pas tout
à fait ça et nous sommes prêts courtois
et recueillie sur des sénateurs la
commission des lois du sénat et nous
avons effectivement par un collaborateur
de la commission recherchant où trouver
monsieur bénard a adressé un mail à
l'avocat et le lui avons dit que
monsieur benalla seraient entendus à une
certaine date et que ne nous permettions
de passer par lui quant à la convocation
jeu-là dresserait dans les prochains
jours en bonne et due forme vous pensez
bien que ces solennel comme une
commission denquête on n'envoie pas un
mail pour dire présentez-vous à telle
heure à tel endroit et était le jour
c'est une affaire qui obéit à une
procédure officielle donc la convocation
sera adressée en temps utile mais elle
sera adressée à y avoir une convocation
donc prochainement est-ce que vous avez
déjà des délais un agenda nous donner
vous savez nous possédons
imperturbablement nous creusons notre
sillon chaque semaine nous avons fait
part de nos auditions nous continuerons
à le faire donc d'ici la fin de la
semaine vous saurez si vous avez la
patience d'attendre qu'ils nous
auditionnons la semaine prochaine que
répondez-vous à l'argument de l'avocat
d'alexandre benalla qui dit qu'il veut
attendre la fin de l'instruction
judiciaire
avant de répondre à cette convocation de
la commission denquête je vous rappelle
que on n'a pas de choix devant les
commissions d enquête
on doit venir moi je peux le faire
chercher par le missié etc
c'est une question qui ne se pose pas et
donc je n'ai pas apprécié la valeur
d'argument qui sont de toute façon
contraire à la loi
mais je dois vous dire que si la
préoccupation est que nous faisons très
attention à ne pas poser de questions
qui sont l'objet d'une enquête
judiciaire
alors c'est exactement comme ceux ci que
je compte m'y prendre tous les sénateurs
de la commission des lois serons
extrêmement vigilants de ne pas poser de
questions qui sont en dehors de notre
domaine vous savez nous avons assez à
faire avec le fonctionnement de l'état
pour ne pas nous intéresser à
d'éventuels voies de fait commises en
marge d'une manifestation le 1er mai
2018 ça c'est la sphère de la justice
nous notre affaire c'est l'état c'est la
séparation des pouvoirs c'est
fonctionnement des institutions
démocratiques c'est le respect de la
constitution
avec un président un gouvernement des
ministres sous l'autorité dès ministres
d administration et personnes qui
n'interfère avec ses administrations en
brandissant une carte bleu blanc rouge
en disant moi je suis de la présidence
de la république
il faudra donc qu'il ya un régime
particulier pour cette audition à ce
qu'on peut s'éteindre à ce qu'il soit
assisté de son avocat à ce que ces
questions soient validées à l'avant
justement pour qu'elles n'empiètent pas
sur l'antenne vous me fournit c'est
l'occasion de rappeler qu'elle
commission denquête n'est pas un
tribunal et par conséquent une audition
n'est pas une comparution et nous ne
possédons pas à des condamnations
nous voulons simplement avoir un
entretien avec chacune des personnes que
nous convoquons pour établir la vérité
des faits par approximations successives
comme disent les mathématiciens
tout ça n'est pas toujours aussi clair
qu'on le voudrait parfois il ya des
contradictions
d'où la nécessité de poursuivre les
auditions pour s'approcher au plus près
de la réalité alors s'agissant de la
possibilité d'être accompagné j'ai
observé et je n'ai aucune raison de m'y
opposer que l'ensemble des personnes
auditionnées sont venus avec des
collaborateurs mais n'ont pas le droit
de parler parce que devant une
commission denquête faut prêter serment
et seules les personnes qui ont prêté ce
héros sont légitimes pour s'exprimer
mais ceci naturellement me paraît tout à
fait acceptable d'être accompagnés d'une
personne de son choix
bien entendu une toute dernière question
philippe à votre réaction à ce qu'a dit
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet ce
matin qui a déclaré qu'il ne pouvait pas
y avoir d'interférence entre
l'instruction judiciaire et la
commission d'enquêté que c'était la
raison pour laquelle alexandre benalla
n'avait pas encore répondu à la
commission denquête vous avez du dépôt
l'habitude de commenter les dires de la
garde des sceaux
mais j'ignorais jusqu'à ce que vous me
posiez la question quel était le conseil
juridique de monsieur benalla